[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL HODSON: Thank you.
Thank you.
Now, can I just check?
Everybody can hear me, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Cool.
OK.
Listen, I am honored
with your presence.
Look at this, for
a group of people.
Thank you so much.
It's going to be my
pleasure to share
a bit of my experience with
you guys today, and girls.
And really talk about the theme
of what we're all about today.
It's Be the Best
Person You Ever Met.
I mean, it's so important.
One of the things that I
learned very early on--
scouting and doing my coaching,
training, whatever-- is,
what was the journey that
I had with my good self?
And often, I was
very disappointed.
So in the next 40 minutes
I want to share with you
a path forward in your life
that you can also pursue.
But you need to
know about me first.
Now, while we start I just want
to share something with you,
because you're
all looking at me.
Very powerful.
Always bear that in mind.
OK.
So what you're going to hear
today is a bit about myself,
my story, how
BodyFitMind came about,
the vision that I have for the
future-- it's in its infancy--
the three pillars
of well-being--
what happens to
all of us when you
get the balance, the
synchronicity of those
three elements correct, my
moments of breakthrough.
And I'm 65 now.
And I spent a long
time getting it wrong.
But just to show you
younger people there's hope.
Now I want to share
a secret with you.
And this is just
between us today.
I wouldn't want it
to go anywhere else.
I'm not perfect.
I don't know what you
were expecting today.
Some fantastically built
person who's super fit,
has got his life in order.
I'm not there yet.
And no one is.
But what we are, and what
you are, and I'm included,
is as human beings
we are amazing.
And we are full of potential
yet to be explored.
I want to share this with you.
I was born in
Birmingham, England.
I-- Does anybody watch
"Peaky Blinders"?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Great show.
I was actually-- the
area where that's set,
that's where I grew up.
Small Heath.
So what you might
find is periodically
I might just slip into a
bit of a Brummie accent.
So just put your hand up
and get me back on track.
I was grammar school-educated.
I got that accent knocked
out, I can assure you.
Let me just go back to that.
So eldest of five kids,
working class family.
University wasn't
an option for me.
I grew up, I did
my GCSEs, which is
Leaving Cert equivalent here.
I got the right grades,
and then I was out to work.
It was no ifs and buts.
University was
for the rich kids.
And my father was
an engineer, and I
was encouraged to take up an
apprenticeship in engineering--
five-year apprenticeship.
I can only say I hated
every moment of it.
Every moment.
But there was
nothing I could do.
And I-- It's the
one thing I learned.
You have to stick with it.
It was on the other
side of Birmingham.
The journey was
maybe an hour a day.
I know that for some people
now that's quite short.
But it was something
that I really disliked.
But because I was expected
to do the right thing
I did the right thing.
That's one thing I
learned very early on.
When I came out of that I
just wanted to get out of it,
and I was searching
for a couple years.
Various jobs--
recruitment, sales,
estimating for a door company.
And I got a job working
in the automotive industry
as an estimator.
Nothing grand,
nothing fantastic.
And I'd been in the job two
weeks when the manager--
god bless him-- came out.
He said, I've got some
good news and bad news.
And I went, Arthur, what is it?
He said, I know you've
only been here two weeks,
but we're closing
down the department.
And we're moving
it to South Wales.
Now I don't know if
you know England,
but South Wales is a
fair distance away.
And whilst I loved
Welsh people, I
didn't fancy working in Cwmbran,
which I had read a lot about.
So I said, well, Arthur, really,
I'm not ready to do that.
I was 23, 24.
He said, well, don't worry.
He says, you work
for the Lucas group--
big group as it was at the time.
He says, we'll find
another job for you.
So every morning he came in
with this big pile of jobs.
And he calls-- those who
agreed not to go to South Wales
were going to be found
another job within the group.
And he came with
his pile of jobs.
Literally, like a stack
of papers like this,
thumbing through.
And he called me
and he said, Paul, I
have got the job for you.
And I says, have you?
And he said, no, no.
I have.
I've got the job for you.
He said, and it's here.
And he placed it on
the side of the table.
And he put his
hand on the others.
Before anything
else, he said, I want
you to go for the
interview for this one.
And I said, what is it, Arthur?
He said, press and
public relations
officer for Lucas group.
How does that sound?
I've got no idea what
you're talking about.
No idea.
I hadn't heard what press
and PR was all about.
And I said, look, can you
just show me the others.
He says, no, I'm sorry.
He says, this is the one
you're going to go for.
If you don't get this job, he
said, I'll show you the others.
So I agreed.
But what he did, he
saw something in me.
Because obviously,
he could see I could
write, as you can as well.
And he saw something in
me that pushed me forward.
And I went to that interview.
And it started a 25-year
career in PR for me.
Now, I call that
divine intervention.
I hadn't chosen my career path.
I was searching for where
I was going forward.
But I had opened myself
up to opportunity,
and that's the key thing.
So 25 years in PR.
I got married, I got
divorced, I had a son.
Led a pretty normal life.
I didn't have any
major disasters.
I did set up my own
business in the PR side.
And then my big moment came.
I remember.
I remember very well.
And I'm going to talk to
you about emotion today.
The whole business went.
It was in the crash in the 90s.
And I realized at
the point I'd lost
track of keeping my eye on it.
I got a partner who was
active in the business,
and we just got it so wrong.
We were the fastest
growing marketing and PR
company in the Midlands area.
And we just lost it.
We went from four
people to 30 people
in the space of 18 months.
Too fast.
And I remember handing
him the keys to my car,
getting on the train to go home.
I was living in
Litchfield at the time.
And I was finished.
I was absolutely finished.
The only thing
that kept me going
was at the time my
partner, and my son.
If anything else, I could have
done something seriously wrong.
By luck, I got introduced
to Tony Robbins.
So I remember I got 300
pounds to buy a computer
to get myself set up properly.
And I ended up buying a ticket
to go and see Tony Robbins.
The sales guy was brilliant.
And I hadn't really
checked him out.
I'd seen an ad in Richard
Branson's "Virgin" magazine
when I was traveling
down to see a friend.
And it was black and white.
It was terrible.
So I rang him up and
said, your ads are awful.
I can help you with that.
And then he sold me a ticket to
see Tony Robbins-- my last 300.
And I walked in there
not really knowing much.
And I walked in.
I got my pack.
There are 5,000 people in the
center in Docklands in London--
the ExCeL Center.
And I walked in--
it was a Thursday afternoon--
and they're all there,
[INAUDIBLE] large and dancing.
And I walked in.
And I went, oh my God,
it's a religious cult.
I could not believe it.
And there was a group
of us at the back,
sitting at the back
like this going,
oh my God, these
people are mental.
Absolutely mental.
And then a big build-up.
Big screens,
everything, you know?
It was just like a rock show.
And in he comes.
And he comes out.
Does anybody know Tony Robbins?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PAUL HODSON: Yeah?
You're all familiar with him.
If not, he's one of the
world's best life coaches.
And he comes on.
He's about six foot, 28.
He's a big guy, and he
comes on-- these big hands.
"Hi, my name's Tony Robbins."
And I went, shit, he's American.
[LAUGHTER]
Not only is it a religious
cult, but he's American.
And he's taken all my money.
Listen.
Within five minutes I could
see he was talking from here.
Not here.
And he said, anybody
who's new here today--
"Anybody new here
today?" he said.
We're all at the back there.
"We are."
He said, "At any point
during this weekend,
if it's not right for you,
then please," he said,
"go to the Administration
desk, and give your pack back,
and we'll give you
a full refund."
And that put my mind to rest.
So the first night
was the fire walk.
I wasn't doing that, by the way.
So the fire walk.
I think it was 7,000 or
8,000 people at our gig,
the fire walk 11 o'
clock at night in the car
park of the ExCeL Center.
He's got everybody psyched up.
Jungle drums playing.
We will take our
shoes and socks off.
And I felt, I might
give this a go.
And as you walk out
into the car park
it's aglow with hot coals,
and ambulances, and firemen,
which didn't help.
And he gets you in a state,
and you're in that stage,
and you go, cool moss, cool
moss, cool moss, and you do it.
And guess what?
Not one burnt foot.
And it showed me the power
that we have within ourselves.
The power that we
have within ourselves
to do anything, really.
I mean, with sensible,
but anything,
really, that we can do
to achieve what we want.
So I come out there, saved me.
Absolutely saved me.
I was on a downward spiral.
One of the things that I did,
and I was working on me--
searching to be the best
person that I'd ever met--
was that I got--
I was never really abused, or
anything like that as a child.
But I did have
some scary moments.
I remember being on the
beach in Cliftonville,
in Margate, east of England
at a very young age.
Being sat in a rubber ring
that my dad had put me in
and pushed me out to sea.
I don't know whether he
was trying to get rid of me
then or later.
But I had a moment.
It was between the
age of six and eight.
And the thing turned over.
But because I sat in it
so deeply I was stuck,
and I was drowning.
I had that moment.
I don't know if anyone's
had that moment where
they might have drowned.
But I was stuck in
that rubber ring,
and everything slowed down.
And I had taken in water, and
it was a most unreal experience.
It was scary, but it was
kind of surreal as well.
And then my dad came and
lifted me out, rescued me.
And what I find with
that is whatever moments
you've had in your
life associated--
that your subconscious
works very well.
And it will repeat the
emotions attached to things
that happened in your life.
Subconscious doesn't know
whether it's real or a replay.
So you get to the--
Has anyone got a favorite song
that brings back a memory?
And when you play that song
you get the same emotion.
You get that feeling.
It could be something--
could be a loved one,
could be when you
first time you met
your partner, the
first time you kissed.
Whatever it was, that
emotion is attached
to you and your subconscious.
And what it does,
it pushes it forward
into the conscious
mind, and you relive it.
This is what happens
to a lot of people.
So moving forward, I got my
PR consultancy on the way.
I went to see him again.
Because you can't take in four
days everything in that Robbins
teaches you.
So I went there
again, and out of it,
on the last day was the
Nutrition and Fitness
Day, which I hadn't
really paid much attention
to the first time I went.
And I came out of there,
and for the first time
I joined the gym.
I wasn't fit at the time.
I'm not fit now.
But I wasn't as fit as
I am now at the time.
So I joined a gym, and
I picked up some work
with a company called Fitness
First doing some evening
work on member services.
Ringing people up and going, why
aren't you coming to the gym?
We love you and miss you.
Because I'm not
coming to the gym.
I didn't realize I was a member.
Can you cancel my membership?
Goodbye.
You know those calls.
So after a period of
time, the manager left.
I was working at home.
Single, just me, working
alone, doing my stuff.
It was OK.
I wasn't complaining.
And they said, would you like to
be general manager of this gym?
We like what you've done so far.
So I took that on board.
And that's how I
then spent my next 15
years in the gym business.
I moved from--
I was living in
Coventry at the time.
Then to Dublin, to run
a gym based in Dublin 6.
At the time LA Fitness,
now the Dartry Health Club.
Great club.
And great people.
And I loved the members.
I'm a people person.
I just absolutely loved
the stories, the journeys,
that people were having.
So it was kind of like a great--
if you like-- experience
for me to be in Dublin.
I came.
I met the girl of
my dreams, finally.
Lovely Mags.
I inherited three
teenage daughters.
That was scary.
Still is.
They're all grown up now.
My own son, his life
has moved forward,
so he's now a head chef
in Lemington in England.
So life changed for me.
Dublin was the--
Dublin was the first
real opportunity for me
to come and get a
grip, and really
get excited about the future of
my life, even at the age I was.
I felt-- I was never confident
that my life was going
to turn out to be anything.
And I was so wrong.
I was so, so wrong.
And we're going to
cover today the reason--
what held me back.
And it's the reason that holds
so many other people back.
So for me it's been a
great learning process.
I've done my coaching training.
The one thing I embraced very,
very full on-- was passionate
about--
the one thing that held me
back will be negatively.
So it kind of ended up for me
like a bit of an awakening.
The great thing that I
learned during that time--
and I want to thank you all--
is Google opened
the world to me.
I set up--
I took a settlement
from the gym.
And I decided that I'm
going to be a life coach.
But the settlement was generous,
so for the first six months
Google was my best friend.
Now what you've done, Google,
is you have let some people out
of the asylum.
Because I learned in that
time that the Earth is flat,
aliens do live on
the moon and Mars.
There are so many
things out there
that I was being-- the
rabbit hole is incredible.
And it just shows you that you
have to be very careful what
you observe.
So I did.
I got myself back on track.
I learned and connected
with a lot of great people.
Life coaching is
one of the biggest,
fastest growing businesses,
certainly in the States.
And it's the area that I
feel very passionate about.
And I started, and I was--
yesterday I had my hair cut.
And it's my first
ever client who
was looking to change,
and move herself forward.
And this is what I
love about coaching.
She only ever had a dream
of having a hair salon.
Only a dream.
And all of the self-doubts,
all of the restrictions,
all of her disbelief that
it could happen to her,
we managed to get through that.
And she opened a small--
with her partner-- a
small salon in Smithfield.
And it's called Hair Cafe Salon.
And yesterday I had the
pleasure of going over
there to their new salon, which
is just a couple hundred yards
away--
five times the size of the
small one that they've got.
And she came up to me and
said, "Paul, do you remember
when I said this was a dream?
And you showed me
the path forward."
And gave me the biggest--
I'm sorry-- gave me
the biggest hug ever.
It was so beautiful.
That is the satisfaction,
as far as I'm concerned,
about coaching.
I don't want to
be massively rich,
but I'd like a little
bit more money, please.
So I've invested a lot so far.
So it's kind of like a great
reward, a great passion for me.
What I learned in the
health club business
is there are a lot of people who
are physically fit but mentally
unfit.
A lot of people that used
my gym were on the treadmill
for 15 minutes.
And I'd say, you're
training for a marathon?
No, no.
I always come and do
this, with their sad eyes.
That was their life.
And it showed me
that whilst fitness
is so very important for all
of us, there is more to it.
Nutrition is so important.
And your mental
fitness is affected
by both of those areas.
So I decided that
my coaching approach
was A, yes, as a
life coach, but I
want to work with other people.
I don't want to be a
singular person going, hey,
I'm Paul Hudson.
And they all go,
God, He's English,
I don't want-- I want to
work with other people.
And I came up with the
concept of BodyFitMind, which
is going to be a collaboration.
A collaboration of
like-minded people,
professionals in the
nutritional area,
professionals in
the fitness area,
the coaching area.
But a go-to source of
information, training,
online courses.
So many things to
improve our lives.
Now you've got
the three of them.
Mental fitness, physical
function, and nutrition.
So integrated approach
about maximizing well-being.
And once one of those
is out of sync--
if you are fit--
and I know a lot of
people who were--
but were eating badly,
or mentally not right,
then you're not well.
Period.
You think you're well,
but you're not well.
You haven't got those--
if you take those-- three
spokes in the wheel
of life you're
not rolling forward
perfectly like you should do.
And you're able to do that.
You're all capable of
getting that right.
And I hear somebody say, how?
And I'm going to
share this with.
It's early days.
I'm going to fall down
this hole in a minute.
It's early days.
It's designed to be a
collaboration of like-minded
people, self-improvement of--
a go-to resource.
And what I want to be
able to do as well,
at some point when
we are succeeding,
is to give something back
to those who need it most,
but who may not be
able to afford it.
We have to do that.
In all of us, in being the
best person you've met,
you've got to give
something back.
Growth and contribution
are very important elements
in our lives.
And I'm going to cover that
in more detail as well.
I remember it was 2008.
I was two years into the
health club in Dublin.
And my assistant manager,
Lisa, who was also a fitness
professional, gave me a book--
you may well have read this book
yourself-- called "The Secret."
Has anyone read that?
Yeah?
Out of interest, how many
people have read "The Secret,"
or watched the DVD?
So it's a good number of you.
It sold 20 million
copies worldwide,
and it's been translated
into 50 languages.
I didn't even know
there were 30 languages.
50 languages I'd
always been interested
in personal development,
but had failed
to carry the momentum
of those events forward.
But you go along to
a Robbins event--
and if you can go, it's
on every year in London.
Unless you want
to go to America--
there's a few on there.
You get to the event,
you get out there,
and everybody's like-minded.
You're having a great
time, and it's high fives,
and then you get back
into the real world.
What happens is people go, is
he a bit tapped now or what?
You've lost your mind.
Family and friends
go, calm down.
What's the matter with you?
Are you OK?
What did they do to you
when you went down there?
And gradually, you slip back
into normality, as they see it.
Not your normality.
Because you're going
around to them--
I went to this great event--
oh, here he is again.
What I found is the great thing
about becoming aware and awake,
is spiritually--
because that comes
into it later once you
start getting up there--
spiritually, you
become two foot taller.
So when you walk into a bar,
or a room, or a gathering,
as you look metaphorically
across the room,
you only connect with
like-minded people.
Now, I'm not dismissing those
people who are not as spiritual
as you are, or connected,
or as learnt as you are.
But those are the people that
you want to be connecting with.
,
Because one of the things
that I had to do was
change my peer group.
I had one point where even my
son went, oh, don't give me
that nonsense, Dad.
I mean, he's different
now because I've
been working on him.
But it is the people that
you are going to be around.
And I think, as Robbins
says, the five people
that you spend most
of your time with
are the people that will
shape you for the future.
Because it's their
influence on you.
So be mindful of that.
So I got my spark.
It was amazing.
And that book-- thank
you, Lisa Martin--
set me on the path.
I was doing my stuff.
And then what did I do?
I went and told everybody I
was going to be a life coach.
Fantastic.
I went, and six years
later I was still
telling people I'm going
to be a life coach.
2012 came.
I'm going to be a life coach.
I've just spent 5,000
quid on the course.
Brilliant.
Two years later, 2014,
there was the course.
I'd started it.
In fairness, I'd
done two modules.
But I was telling everybody.
And all I was doing
was talking the talk.
And as Robbin says,
don't talk the talk.
Walk the walk.
So what was wrong with me?
I just went into myself.
I didn't have the self-belief.
I didn't have the commitment.
I wasn't ready
for it, obviously,
because my journey
with me was more about
learning from my experiences.
But not being the
best pupil, perhaps.
So there was one
thing holding me back.
This is what I Iearned.
Being kinder to myself
is what I also learned.
I stopped blaming
others for where I was.
I was livid when I
lost my business.
I blamed everybody.
It was my fault. I took
my eyes off the ball.
I got what I deserved, but
I can now live with that.
And also, I was beginning to
understand how my mind worked--
the power of my emotions
and my thinking.
So the one thing I realized--
being kinder to myself.
I got rid of my
stinking thinking,
I looked deep within myself.
I exercised, and
I woke up earlier.
I reviewed what
food I was eating.
And I practiced gratitude
on a daily basis.
And that's not like
going, oh, thank you.
It's just being
grateful that you've
got another sunny morning,
as we've had in Dublin
for the last three weeks.
Just be grateful for the
smallest things in your life--
that you've actually
got a bed to sleep on.
Be grateful.
And I'll tell you what.
When you're being grateful
you can't be depressed.
Those two don't live together.
So gratitude is a powerful lift.
I haven't really read
anything for 20 years.
Really.
I pick a book up, I buy a
book, and I put it down.
And nothing was inspiring me.
And with "The Secret,"
that opened up
a whole new world for me.
So "The Secret" was a--
"The Four Agreements."
Has anyone read "The
Four Agreements,"
by Don Miguel Ruiz?
Goes back to the Toltec
civilization in South America.
And it's the most amazing book.
Just four agreements
that we live with.
And if I can find my slide
I'll tell you what they are.
The agreements
are life-changing,
if you can embrace them.
I have a slide on
this in a few moments.
But I'd read books early on--
"Grow Rich While You
Sleep," "As a Man Thinketh,"
which is one of
the very earliest
personal development
books-- goes back to 1918.
"Psycho-Cybernetics,"
"The One Thing,"
"Man's Search for Meaning."
My book-- it's my
Kindle, actually.
My Kindle is heavy.
Probably I have
40, 50 books now.
I've probably read more
books in the last 12 months
than I had in the last 20 years.
Seriously.
And that's where
you've got to be.
You really have to be there.
Because it's about your journey.
So this had a real impact on me.
Four simple things
to lead you forward.
Be impeccable with your word.
Speak with integrity.
Saying what you mean.
Avoid using the word to speak
against yourself, or to gossip
about others.
Use the power of your word in
direction of truth and love.
I'm laughing because I can know
some of you are going, no way.
I love gossiping about people.
Love that.
It's a powerful, powerful thing.
It's a powerful
discipline to have.
Don't take anything personally.
Usually, if someone is
giving you a bad time
it's because they are having
a bad time themselves.
Really.
Don't make assumptions.
Don't assume.
What is the
definition of assume?
Makes an ass out of you and me.
Assume.
Simple.
So very clear and obvious, but
we do make those assumptions.
And always do your best.
Some days will be
better than others.
Some days you will
be on top form.
Other days you won't.
But as long as you go home, and
you can say I've done my best,
that's fine.
So powerful stuff.
All of this stuff, all
of this information
is available to you.
Read more.
Exercise more.
Learn more.
Learn something new.
I was speaking earlier
about Eckhart Tolle's book,
"The Power of Now,"
which is kind of
fundamental about mindfulness.
So if you are into
learning something new,
look at yoga and mindfulness.
Because that is such
a powerful thing
to get your head in the right
place, to learn and grow.
Being in the now.
You know when your
head's racing forward
and you're thinking back?
And all of that's
distracting you.
Change your story.
That's what Robbins--
I was blaming everyone.
I came out of there--
Robbins going,
"Change your story."
My story was I lost my
business because, you know,
he ran off with the money.
And they never liked me anyway--
the people who worked for--
I gave them a job.
Oh, I was pathetic.
I was pathetic.
But change your story.
Volunteer.
I did a year with a
ALONE, I went and looked
after a guy who was deaf
and partially sighted.
And when they
coupled me with him
I went, well, how am I
going to talk to him?
I mean, he's deaf.
And he won't even see me.
And he was partially sighted.
And we used to have a little
white board with a pen.
And I'd say, hello, Michael.
How are you?
And he'd take it off me with
his big, thick, spyglass.
And he'd write.
And that's how we
communicated for nine months.
And you know, I got to the point
where I said to Mags one night.
I said, look, Mags, I
really haven't got time
to go and see Michael anymore.
And she went, are
you sure about that?
I went, yeah.
I'm really busy.
She said, you spend one
hour a week with him.
She said, his week is when
you arrive to see him.
That's what it's about.
Think about that.
So I did, and I carried on.
And ALONE, you only look after
or connect with an older person
for 12 months.
So I'm going to do it again.
And do it with something else.
But so rewarding.
So rewarding.
Food.
I'm not going to give you
a super diet plan today.
There are so many
things out there.
But be sensible about your food.
Sugar is the worst
thing, and it's
got 67 disguises when you look
at the contents on the back
of any food that you buy.
Oh, there's no sugar in this.
Fructose.
What's that?
Is that-- yeah, it's sugar.
Understand how
sugar is disguised,
because it's worse than heroin.
You're addicted to it.
It is worse.
And it's killing people.
And it's making them obese.
And it's damaging their health.
You.
Look at what you're
eating, and lots more.
I didn't become vegetarian,
but I tried a 60-day no meat
program.
And it worked for
me, It was great.
But I'm not saying--
I have probably red meat
once or twice a week.
Organic, if you can get it.
Same with your vegetables.
Go fresh.
Anything in a tin or a packet
might be full of preservatives.
Just be mindful.
You can live and
eat a better way.
Get a coach.
There's loads of us now.
But seriously, if you want
a change in your life,
you might need someone just
to give you that direction.
To be that hand of support,
to be that person that you
can share some of your
deepest fears with,
without being judged.
To help you through what
might be a challenge.
To give you that courage to
step out onto a fire walk.
All of that is available
to you, but find a coach.
OK.
Very quick interlude.
I can see that we're all
kind of rearing to go.
I'm going to just
give you some of the--
I'm very visually
empowered, so I
like to have a lot of
things that influence me.
So you can do that.
And I just wanted to
share some stuff with you.
All of these are on my
Instagram page, by the way.
BodyFitMind Instagram.
So these are some of the
things that have inspired me,
or I've heard, or
I created myself.
Somebody is always
doing what somebody else
said couldn't be done.
How true is that?
You hear the story about
Colonel Sanders and KFC.
1,000 stops he made.
Thousands.
He traveled the country.
You've traveled America with
this recipe for chicken.
1,000 nos he got.
1,000-plus nos.
And he was my age.
He was in his 60s.
But he never gave up.
He never gave up.
"The perfect day.
Going to bed with a dream,
and waking up with a purpose."
How powerful is that?
I love that one.
This is very powerful as well.
"With this journey,
find, becoming,
and meeting the better
person that's within you.
When you love yourself enough
you begin to see your purpose,
and you can gently wean
yourself off distractions."
This is very close
to me as well.
We all know people who may
suffer with eating disorders--
I do.
Or addictions, who know that
they're damaging their bodies.
This is a quote by E.E Cummings.
"And I said to my body softly,
'I want to be your friend.'
It took a long
breath and replied,
'I've been waiting my whole
life for this.'" How powerful is
that?
That's me in a
couple years time.
Stretch the wrinkles.
"Searching for happiness?"
Everybody is searching
for happiness.
The tools that you need to find
that happiness are within you.
Be more helpful.
Be more grateful.
Be kinder.
Share more.
And love more.
"How you feel in
the morning is going
to determine the
rest of your day."
Now I bought into the idea--
my most creative time.
Some people are morning
people, some people
are afternoon people, some
people are evening people.
That's BS.
I was an afternoon
person, because I
lay in bed for the first
four hours of the day.
I'm going to be
great this afternoon,
but I'm not a morning
person anyway.
The best time, your
most creative time,
is when you wake up.
The first two hours of your day.
The discipline that
you need to be doing--
don't-- I'm guilty myself.
You wake up, and
you're like this.
Morning, love.
I'm just going through this.
I've got a message.
Everybody's doing it.
Don't turn your phone on.
Go and sit yourself
outside if you can.
Have a coffee.
Embrace what's around you.
One of the things
that we've done--
my partner and I--
and that's why we're so
happy to see the dog here--
in order for us to move
forward we sat down,
and we said, what do we want
to do that we can do together.
And we listed
everything we liked.
And we liked dogs.
And last year we launched
Naturally Barking Mad.
Doggie Daycare.
Dog walking.
A few dogs here.
It's unbelievable.
People think more about their
dogs than they do themselves.
And through that-- it's a
bit tough at the moment,
because dogs obviously
don't know the time.
So when they see that
it's light they bark.
So June the 21st being the
longest day of the year,
at 4:30 we're up, because
the dogs need to go outside.
We have two dogs of our own.
They need to be fed.
And it's dark at 11 o'clock.
So we [INAUDIBLE].
We've had some long, long days.
But it's brilliant,
because we love dogs.
And this is how I
came here today.
Through Leanne,
looking after her dog.
There he is.
One of my favorites.
Todd.
Absolutely gorgeous, man.
He's got attitude, but
I love him to bits.
So we looked beyond what we
thought were our capabilities.
And just by doing that,
just by me looking in,
with Mags looking in,
we found something
that really excited us.
And we haven't looked
back, really, on that.
So-- sorry about this.
One of the things I learned
on my Robbins training
is these are the six
human needs that we
will have as human beings.
Everyone.
And usually two of these are
driving forward in your life.
Mine was-- and it
changes as you grow.
So there is a test.
And if anyone wants to do
a test please contact me,
and I'm more than happy
to give you a free--
it's not like a tarot card
reading or anything like that.
A free analysis that you
can use to direct yourself.
Certainty.
That's the first need.
There are four needs that
are important in terms
of human needs.
Concept.
But growth and contribution are
a little bit more spiritual.
So certainty.
We all need to have certainty.
We all need to know that
when you go home tonight
you've got a house to live in.
Got all that.
But also, we need variety.
Because if you were certain--
you need some
variety in your life.
Significance.
And people can use these both
positively and negatively.
Love and connection.
We all need that
love and connection.
If a baby is born, and is
disconnected from its mother,
and left alone, it will die.
It needs that physical
contact to thrive.
Growth.
Big one for me.
We've got to be growing
all of the time.
If we're not
growing we're dying.
And contribution.
At some point in time,
give something back.
I see people--
We've got a lot of
homeless people,
but I see people, regularly,
helping people out
on the streets.
It's sad that they're
in that situation.
If I could help and change
that I would do that.
We all need to think
hard about that.
I know that they've
got problems.
But if I give that guy a coffee,
and I do, or a two euro piece.
People will go
and be judgmental.
He's going to buy drugs
with that, What if he's
going to buy drugs with it?
I'm sorry.
I'm not feeding his habit,
but I'm trying to help him.
Don't judge people.
Just help them.
Give them some help.
And sometimes don't
give them money.
Give them food.
Give them something to drink.
So growth and contribution.
Those are the six human needs.
There's a whole
presentation, and I'm not
going to keep you too
much longer on that.
So I can do that for you.
If anyone is interested,
please contact me.
I'd be honored to share
the information with you.
So the one thing.
Any ideas?
What is the one thing that
holds most people back?
The one thing?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Fear.
PAUL HODSON: Fear.
Yeah.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL HODSON: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Doubt.
Doubt.
Self-doubt.
PAUL HODSON: Self-doubt.
Yeah.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Other
people sometimes.
PAUL HODSON: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: There's things that
other people may [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL HODSON: So being judged?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Yeah, OK.
Those are all collective
items, and they are all
very, very, very significant.
But this is the
simplest thing of all.
This is the one thing.
When I got my head
around it, I didn't
realize that this was me.
When I got my head
around it I thought,
how can I be like
this for so long?
How could I have been
like this for so long?
Procrastination.
It's such a simple thing.
Everybody does it.
You have your to-do list.
You build the barriers .
You don't get off your
backside and do the things
that you need to do.
You're scared to do the
things you need to do.
You dislike-- you're bored
with the things you need to do.
And it's easily,
easily resolved.
Because once you get that
right, and you take action,
your life changes.
Your life will change.
I was the world's worst.
My training to be a coach,
I thought about it in 2008.
And I didn't become a
coach until 2015, '16.
Those were the things.
Purely for no other reason
than procrastination.
No other reason.
I didn't do what was necessary
to do what I needed to do.
So in doing that, by taking
action, by having a plan--
and yes, I know
it's a sales pitch--
I've written a book.
And it's my first book.
And it's the first book in
the series of other books
I'm working on.
And I'm trying not
to procrastinate
to write the second, but
I have a title for it.
And it's just about
getting that done.
And I've read-- and if
you do Amazon search
there's loads of books
on procrastination.
There's science on
procrastination.
There's people trying to
understand what procrastination
is all about.
It's-- just do it.
Just be active.
Get to do what you need to do.
Five steps.
Stop the distraction
and get a grip.
Do the one thing.
There's a great book on that.
Don't try and multitask.
We cannot multi-- we
think we can multitask,
but we can only do
one thing at a time.
Get organized.
I now have a diary.
A paper diary.
Does anyone keep a journal?
No.
No one keeps a journal.
Some of the greatest minds
in the world keep a journal.
This is your journey
with yourself.
Do this every day.
Get yourself a book.
And don't go, ugh, I really
hated my hair this morning,
and I feel so fat.
I can't-- No, no.
It's not designed for that.
Keep it positive.
Capture all your memories.
And as they build
up, you'll be amazed
how many great ideas you've
had that you forgot about.
And do what you need to do.
So focus.
Focus is the one thing
that really worked for me.
Once I found-- some used to
say, Paul, you're not focused,
and I get really negative.
They were right.
I get really negative.
Focus is the one great
thing that we all
need to explore and find.
Don't go back.
Once you've mastered
procrastination don't go back.
OK.
So energy.
Brain scientists can
measure energy levels
in key areas of our body now.
There's a Ted talk by
Dr. Wendy Suzuki who's
a neuroscientist,
who shows, and can
measure the power of exercise.
And all those great
things it releases
in the chemistry of our brains.
Measurements, electrically
within our brains.
The very skin that
we have, it wasn't
the skin we had 12 months ago.
Every cell in our body
is being replaced.
So the you that sits
here now is not the you
that was here last year.
Don't worry about that too much.
So thoughts and energy.
Jodi Spencer.
Dr. Jodi Spencer
talks about the quan--
I know it's a little
bit woo, but he
talks about the quantum
field, where what we think
is what we attract.
That is so-- that so works.
Our vision board at home--
vision boards are good as well--
it's got dogs on it.
When we first did
it 18 months ago--
doggie business.
And I said, Mags, take it down.
We have enough
dogs to look after.
It works.
Believe that it works.
And our subconscious
runs in the background
but drives our experience,
and forms our habits.
It's not conscious of what is
real, or what is not real--
whether it's a memory
or it's happening now.
It still stirs up the
same emotions within you.
I think you've had
enough of me talking.
I'm going to show you how the
energy works in your body.
I want you all to stand up.
Find a little bit of space.
Put down your stuff, obviously.
I'm going to show you
a two-minute exercise.
Here's the runners.
I want to show you
in two minutes,
and demonstrate to you, just
how energized your body is.
Now you're going to have
to bear with me on this.
All you've got to do--
and watch me-- is I want
you to bounce like this.
And I want you to really
shake those hands.
So we've actually got
some really good momentum.
Are you good with that?
I know there's a few
wobbly bits going around,
but don't worry about that.
Are you ready?
Two minutes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL HODSON: If I
can get this started.
There's a timer here.
Can you get that to start?
Ah.
Didn't move the mouse.
OK, here we go.
Here we go.
Two minutes of this now.
You grunt.
We've already gone 10 seconds.
Look.
Keep that going.
Keep that energy going.
Bounce.
I can feel the floor moving.
It's brilliant.
Our combined weight brought
down the Google building.
So just keep that going.
And just bounce, and
feel those legs moving.
If you want to jump up a bit you
can, but don't hang your head
on the TV there.
So we've got--
and this is what--
all of this energy is
going through your body.
And at the end of
this, you're going
to be so amazed, because we got
this shared electrical energy
going through.
Really [INAUDIBLE] now.
OK, good.
Good, I like that handshake.
We're nearly a minute in.
Come on.
Let's stay with it.
OK.
You can have a drink afterwards.
You can lie down
afterwards if you want.
So let's keep that going.
Those shaky hands.
Those wobbly bits.
Can you feel your
calves tightening up?
I can.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Yeah?
OK.
If you're feeling a little
bit hard on the legs just
do the upper body.
Keep that going.
42 seconds in.
OK.
Are we good?
Anybody tired yet?
Two minutes.
This is killing me.
Oh, my God.
30 seconds.
Counting down.
OK.
Are we ready?
This is an exercise you can do
every morning when you wake up.
Obviously not naked, because
that could damage you.
So we've got it.
We're moving.
16.
OK.
Nearly there guys.
Two minutes of this.
Seems so long, doesn't it?
Since we started this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: OK.
And you've not really done
much, except shake around a bit.
There you go.
Now stop.
Stop.
OK.
Now put your arms out.
Can you feel that tingle?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Can you feel
the tingling in your body?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL HODSON: Yeah?
That is energy that
you've just released
by moving around, rushing
through every cell
in your body.
Look at that.
That is so simple.
If you ever feel tired
do that for two minutes.
But try and do that
every morning if you can.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL HODSON: OK.
We're nearly done.
Hang on.
I have one-- four
minutes of your time,
to share something with you
that I saw the other day.
And it's just a bit of
a motivational speech.
So please, bear with me.
Hang on.
I'm doing this wrong again.
Oh, no.
There we go.
OK.
Oh, it's an ad.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So many of you are
looking for fulfilment--
PAUL HODSON: Any volume?
- --where it can never be found.
You were looking for fulfilment
in things, possessions, money,
recognition.
You're looking for fulfillment
in another person, praise
from a parent, love
from another person,
a "well done" from the world.
But here's the problem.
You can never find
it outside of you.
It can only be found within you.
All the happiness and joy
you could ever hope for,
and more, it is within you now.
- The truth is we don't
need all those other things
to complete our life.
We don't need anything
outside ourselves
to be happy right now.
Think back to a
time in your life
you didn't have those
things you seek.
You were still happy.
Perhaps when you were a child,
perhaps not too long ago.
The reason why you were
happy without those things
is down to what you
chose to focus on.
And your focus wasn't
on what was not there.
It was on what was there.
And happiness is
always there if you
choose to focus on finding it.
We tend to always look for
happiness outside ourselves,
but we all know that it
doesn't come from there.
Whatever we perceive as
reality becomes our reality.
If you listen to the world,
and the opinions of others,
you will come to believe
that happiness is only
gained once you make money,
or get that nice car,
that great house.
Why do we want
those things anyway?
Why do we want the car,
the house, the money,
that perfect person?
All of it, without
exception, we want
because we believe getting
it will make us better.
We believe it will make us feel
better, make us feel happier.
- Don't get dragged into
the expectations of society.
You don't need things like
that to be happy and complete.
What you need is
always within you.
It never goes away.
You are complete right now.
- Look within you.
Feel the truth that is.
You can decide to
be happy right now.
- Find something
to be grateful for.
Choose to lift others up.
Give attention,
rather than seek it.
Find your life purpose,
and set goals that
light the spark within you.
Believe in yourself.
Believe you deserve it all.
Believe your life has meaning.
There is nothing you cannot
accomplish when you are free
from the burden of looking
for things outside of yourself
to fulfil you.
Just know you have the answers.
Trust your intuition.
Trust everything will
be OK in the end.
Everything will be
great in the end.
magical in the end.
[END PLAYBACK]
PAUL HODSON: That's it, guys.
I just want to say
one thing to you.
Sorry.
Can I just get that back
to the final screen?
I want to say thank you so much
for sharing this time with me
today.
It's been my pleasure, and
an honor to be amongst you.
You've been a great
group to talk to.
And it's-- that's it--
it's all about that journey.
It's all about your search.
And I want to thank you.
I want to thank Leanne for
bringing the dog into my life,
and bringing me into
contact with the team.
The team themselves
have been brilliant.
You've been the best
audience I've ever talked to.
Seriously.
I'm working hard to be the
best person I've ever met.
And I want you to do the same.
You can all do it individually.
We can make the world a
better place for our children.
We worry about what's happening
in the world, but individually,
one by one, we can
make a difference.
And maybe we can make a
better world for our children.
And our children's children.
Just by being the best
person you've ever met.
Thank you very much.
I'm honored to be here.
[APPLAUSE]